Ready? As I'll ever be
You really think high school is gonna be all that different from middle school? I don't want people to think I'm a loser. Worst case you always have me
What's up bro?
Yo, tighty!
Keeping it clean tighty? Oh no, Maddy Datner
Everyone is on her feed. Did you guys see  Maddy's eyebrows from last weekend? On fleek!
What about this one?  Go with the football pick, it's more iconic, like a Taylor Swift song. Oh you are so right
Prom is just around the corner
Guessing you still don't have a date for the prom?
Prom, is about sex
Come on Maddy, g2g
Maddy it's not what it looks like. So it's not my boyfriend and best friend making out for some optical illusion of that
Well if you'll believe that then yes. Oh my god
Why are you doing this now?
I know that much being crowned queen means to you, which only makes me want it more
Now just reflect, and listen to my urine hit the water
I reflected. My whole life has been a lie
Maddy what's wrong? I hate high school
I never thought that popular kids in school had anything to get this upset about. Maybe she's not that popular
You okay? Why did all of this have to happen right before prom? That's it! What's it? Prom
What if we ruined it? Who would want to help us?
Every kid you and your ex friends ever made fun of. The sweat stain on your back looks like the United States of America
I'm posting this
This is for all the A-holes who destroyed high school for us
We're in. We'll make it a night that they never forget. You're gonna take a selfie
Hold on. We have to take at least 40 or 50 to make sure we all look good
Part of me just wishes I could go to prom
Destroy that prom. Let me take off those tighty whities. Are you high? A little, but that doesn't mean I don't mean what I say
You guys ready to make this a prom they will never forget? Hell yes! I am so turned on right now
How do you do this? 39 more here we go